meanwhile tonight the Vegas strong
resiliency Center is encouraging you to
make a lantern it's a way to honor the
victim's survivors and First Responders
from that night and just a beautiful
tribute can
joining us live from the healing Garden
this morning with more on the importance
and really the impact of this Lantern
ceremony Candace good morning
good morning to you good morning folks
this is just one of the many events that
will be honoring the 58 lives lost a lot
of people have already registered 2 000
it really does explain the need for an
event like this but even though they run
out of kits we're able to show you how
to make your own so you can also join in
on this event now I'm joined by
Jacqueline Harris a mental health
provider who will be helping people do
this process and she's going to start on
it right now show us a little bit how
this works and also tell us really
quickly why this event would be so
helpful for people trying to get to the
healing process I think this event will
be helpful because it's individualized
so you can customize your own Lantern
and decorate it how you like and keep it
and continue to display it so that we
really continue to honor the lives that
we lost and those that survived thank
you Jacqueline and this is simple enough
you really just put this on there and
then you put a candle in there I'm gonna
let her continue that while I talked to
Neil Pereira from Vegas strong
resiliency Center will be holding at
this event now I know you guys have done
so many events to honor the 58 lives
lost how is this culminating and all
that especially at the five-year mark
because it focuses on healing and the
light that has come out of this tragedy
you know it can it can be hard to focus
on you know the hope and the peace when
there's negativity out there but this
will help them do that thank you so much
Janelle and thank you as well Jacqueline
you guys are doing an amazing thing for
the community so need it and you guys
can join in as I said you can make one
yourself plenty of time to do so now
this event will take place tonight at
six at the United Way Southern Nevada of
course you can also check it out online
at 6 30 on the Vegas strong resiliency
Center YouTube page and also have it on
their website shortly after of course we
have you covering all those details on
our website as well 8newsnow.com for now
for live from the hill and garden I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now